if another Pearl Harbor happened right
now there would probably be riots
against Joe Biden for having caused the
escalation by funding war in Ukraine see
that's interesting you say that because
I'm not at all convinced that the right
wing is capable of actually rioting like
January 6 was as close as they got and
that was pretty tepid no I I agree let's
let's let's break it down by actual how
things go the US government then calls
in a draft of some sort right and then
you get massive conflict with people
resisting and rejecting police are going
to be split in half I mean cops are
already signed with a bunch of vote
policies but let's just put it simply
that if anything happened to this
country that resulted in hard military
action there would be
it would be Bedlam yeah you're not going
to get conservatives being like this is
the one issue where we've decided to
stand and salute Joe Biden never gonna
happen Okay especially when you look at
69 of Republicans believing that Biden
is illegitimate they will never salute
that man under any circumstances